this past champion believes the gesture
distracts from the sport
in the 80s we were concentrating on
getting on with the business today there
seems to be more
soap boxes and people expressing how
they feel and i
really don't think the olympics is that
place there's a there's a time and a
place for it it's about unity and
diversity
and i think that uh we need to stay pure
in that respect and keep
focused on what the sport's all about
you know and bringing people together
and not creating a divide and you think
taking the knee does that
i do think that some sometimes it gets a
step too fast
but britain's best ever sprinter has
called taking the knee a fundamental
human right
athletes can now kneel before competing
but dinasha smith wants podium protests
to be allowed
too like in 1968 when american sprinters
tommy smith
and john carlos stood against racism on
the medal stand in mexico
really uh no change of the rule
i mean they're just trying to put a
band-aid on it and give me the
impression that they made a change but
they didn't make any significant change
uh you know like uh if if i'm gonna
protest i'm gonna go into london bridge
in protest i'm not going to go
beneath the bridge underneath the bridge
behind the bridge
i'm going to be on the bridge to make
that statement why because i'm trying to
reach as many
people as i possibly can a long way from
tokyo the gb home crowd
are watching on from afar and here they
do care
about the statements as much as a sport
i think they should have a right to go
against racism
i don't believe that they should be
banning those type of staff because
everyone has their own
like views and everything they are human
beings individuals with their own values
and beliefs and i think
you have to respect the athlete for who
they are at the same time so if it's a
personal choice absolutely
it's a message that needs to be heard
american footballer colin kaepernick was
the first to make taking the knee
symbolic
since then it's become a much bigger
statement team gb women took the knee in
their opening match
the finishing line though will be on the
podium ali fortescue
sky news